[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
afida turner au théâtre à laquelle
j'avais deux semaines au théâtre trévise
a été complet alors annoncé sa présence
en bourse avec 4000 personnes à
les compléter c'est même maintenant
couture même les fringues son talent
mais tous écoutent chez aux modèles sont
sales de téléphone date de soixante dix
s'est même écoulé au moins c'est que
c'est une famille que tu regardes
pendant une demi-heure il ya des gens
qui rient au dix huitième degré dans la
salle ça tu penses que les gens voient
la voix pour soit 2 hagen
pense pas je ne sais bien sûr il va j'ai
un troisième nom j'ai un troisième nom
avec florian oui ça fait 20 ans qu'elle
nous fait rire et elle continue sauf que
je plains nouvelle nous fait pas rire
pour les raisons qu'elle pense être les
bonnes c'est à dire que je ne sois pas
que je suis pas convaincu que sa pièce
est drôle par contre les gens se moquent
d'elle depuis 20 ans elle est conçue
pour vous c'est une usurpatrice pardon
c'est une usurpatrice comme on dit mais
je pense qu'elle ne sait même pas et
qu'elle leur accorde mais c'est elle et
elle est perdue en fait non alors il ya
des gens aussi qui pensent que c'est
bien qu'elle va lutter admin et elle et
moi je le connais très bien et les
bijoux sophie dion
jada
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous faites
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais ça fait maintenant on n'a pas vu là
ce soir effet les cours florent s'est
plaint on fait les prolongations au lieu
d'encourager quelqu'un qui se sort de la
merde alors il est bien allé questionner
soit c'est un c'est un compliment non
mais puisque juni que sa fille d abb on
est là où
[Applaudissements]
et avec moi celle à ta place wada
sommeil voilà voilà voilà les beaux
dossiers quand on est une star comme toi
il faut forcément des critiques
possibles mais coûte 1 a vu ça comme un
trou du cul tout moment
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'ai pas été très gentils
je le connais pas on s'en fout et
aimerait maintenant là c'est méchant
écoutez vous écouter vous mais j'écoute
magistrats qu'ils méritent genre on peut
pas être lancée disputé avec toi ça le
problème ce nom ne vous est pas brillant
moyens et coûte un peu d'argent qui sont
autour de nez au tour du
lycée mais regardez je regarde
raconte cinéma tout le monde s'en fout
de ta tête bon ben on arrête d'en parler
pas gentil c'est déjà ma fille d'un juge
et les gens à ouidah avoue d'un vrai
encourageant que sait-on sortir mettrai
jamais c'est pas
évident à semaine rapide à jonathan
c'est là que tu te fais mal un témoin
témoin témoin merde tu te plaît on peut
écouter on peut s'écouter et écoutent
qu'il a à dire et après tu réponds gml -
il m'intéresse ça dérange pas une
reddition mais c'est pas baissé mais je
m'en fous
il écoute le n'est pas dans le match et
robineau
palach l'hystérie une puce toi
alors s'il te plaît de terminer nous
diriger pendant deux minutes
ils ont tapé reina dirige le franchement
dans les yeux jeudi globalement ce que
beaucoup 90 bruges en belgique ans pense
de toi et deuxièmement il est
fait quoi toi dans ta life il a fait
part aujourd'hui où sa fille leila ben
merde t'es
projet
détaillé feed ah tu te grandirais en at
on moins vulgaire en étant plus
respectueux
[Applaudissements]
mais bébé mon coeur mon coeur pour
rappel on rappelle parce qu'il rappelle
que la pièce a été un succès pendant
quatre semaines et on visionne il mardi
mercredi la semaine prochaine au théâtre
trévise la semaine tout c'est quoi et
oui et tu sais quoi aiguillonné mois et
guillaume et moi on verra te voir de
beaucoup plaisir et non mais moi je suis
ici aussi mais là maintenant il faut que
tu te calmes à tout petit peu parce que
là je sens qu'il ya un petit peu de
personnes en tout cas je me fais passer
par des gens qui tout à fait tout à bien
l'aventuré fils et la fille ne l'apprend
termine que les gens quand on se connaît
suffisamment ouais enfin on
écoute ça peut te servir ce qu'il te dit
non mais ça n'est pas une mauvaise
personne
guillaume constructive comme comme et a
filé à ce qui peut pas dire de quelqu'un
il m'intéresse pas parce qu'il va pas me
faire faire un film n'y a pas que les
gens avec qui vont que mahiedine ça
m'affecte pas quant à jean paul gaultier
qui vient voir les semaines se permet de
critiquer mes rivaux fois c'est son
frère éric gauthier
merci